profiter de l'image de papa pour se
faire une place au soleil c'est le
procédé choisi par marie-caroline le pen
janvier 1986 à 26 ans la fille aînée de
jean marie le pen est à pied d'oeuvre
pour les élections législatives au côté
de son père elle fait alors partie des
figures du front national parce que je
suis le fils au front national
je répète que sa fille jure était encore
toujours et pour ces législatives le fn
incarnée par le clan le pen entend faire
la différence
pendant la campagne le patriarche à la
réputation sulfureuse de lisser son
image et il peut compter sur son aîné ce
type gentil drôle qui dont ceux qui
aiment ce musée qui malheureusement il
ya beaucoup de choses à faire on se voit
rarement
cette année là pour la première fois le
fn fait son entrée à l'assemblée avec 35
députés élus galvanisés par ce score
jean marie le pen se présente à la
présidentielle de 1988 et marie-caroline
le pen aux législatives on l'a
questionné alors sur son ambition
politique
la suite pourquoi non robert spon
dynastie la fille le pen sera ensuite de
toutes les élections
élue conseillère régionale d'île de
france elles portent vigoureusement les
couleurs du fn aux cantonales de 1992
alors arrêtez cette comédie qui consiste
à invectiver les communistes à la
télévision lors que vous accordez avec
eux sur le terrain aux législatives de
une fois ce n'était pas le jeu de la
gauche le front national fait le jeu du
front national aux élections cantonales
de 1994 d'alternative de pouce au pays
c'est le fond de l'air et aux
législatives de 1997 dans les yvelines
un jour de campagne son père vient la
soutenir à mantes la jolie
une journée qui va vite dégénérer on le
voit ici au ralenti or de nuit jean
marie le pen plaque contre le mur la
candidate socialiste
annette calebasse bergar
[Musique]
la mésaventure va laisser des traces
marie-caroline le pen perd l'élection au
profit de sa concurrente ps et l'année
suivante en 1998 elle démissionne du fn
et rejoint le rival de son père bruno
mégret impardonnable pour jean marie le
pen
j'ai l'habitude des trahisons familiale
mais si on prend la règle démocratique
je constate que deux filles sur 3
suivent leurs pairs et lui font
confiance
deux ans plus tard en 2000
marie-caroline le pen quitte finalement
le parti mégrétistes après plusieurs
années de discrétion politique elle
réintègre le fn en 2015 et participe à
la présidentielle de sa soeur en 2017
aujourd'hui les relations avec son père
semble apaisée et les mets du clan le
pen fait son grand retour en politique
[Musique]